dans l'année je me permets 2 mois de un
petit peu de de de folie comme ça pour
pour changer un peu le rythme mais mais
je reviens vite à vite à la à la raison
euh je suis quelqu'un de de très
instable vraissemblablement par par mon
enfance quelque part où j'ai j'ai
toujours été tremballé un petit peu de
droite à gauche j'ai pas eu vraiment de
parents pour pour
m'élever mon père m'a abandonné j'avais
j'avais 7 mois et donc
j'ai toujours cherché comme ça c'est une
espèce de de famille et et
puis je me suis trompé très
souvent et puis jusqu'au jour où j'ai
rencontréa et ça a été la bonne voilà
est-ce que c'est parce qu'elle a aussi
souffert elle aussi dans son enfance que
vous vous êtes retrouvé sur cette même
souffrance je crois qu'il y a des choses
similaires parce que aussi Leti et
quelqu'un de d'enfant divorcé elle a
vécu plus avec son père qu'avec sa mère
elle a vécu à Miami pendant très
longtemps pendant plus de 10 ans avec
son père et je crois qu'il il y a des
similitudes oui certainement
vraisemblablement elle avait besoin
aussi de de de peut-être de quelque
chose de de ce ce désir de de d'aimer de
fonder une famille et je dois dire que
depuis qu'on a notre petit notre petit
jade un petit boutchou c'est vrai que
même moi je deviens complètement gâuse
moi je sortais beaucoup je pouvais pas
rester chez moi le soir je sortais TS je
sortais tous les soirs et puis bon
là c'est vrai que j'ai pas envie de
sortir quand je suis chez moi bon c'est
ça la vous revenez toujours à la famille
c'est ça le plus important oui mais
c'est important vous savez puis on
arrive à un certain âge o on a besoin
d'autres choses quand on a 20 ans ça
c'est certain
aussi moi vous savez j'ai moi la petite
Jade a changé toute ma vie parce que
j'ai eu un fils j'étais très jeune
j'avais un fils j'ai eu un fils à 22 ans
qui est David j'étais sur les routes
perpétuellement je ne l'ai pas vu
grandir puis sa maman et moi on s'est
séparé donc David il est parti vivre
avec sa sa maman à Los Angeles donc je
le voyais je le voyais pour pour leséc
de vacances vous allez le voir comme ça
15 jours mais jeai pas oui bien sûr je
le regrette je l'ai pas vu grandir chez
moi ça a été un manque toute ma vie
ensuite euh j'ai eu la ma petite Laura
de on s'est séparé avec la maman aussi
Laura a vécu a vécu avec sa maman moi
j'étais toujours en train de partir
aussi à droite et à gauche par pour un
métier donc je l'ai pas vu grandir dans
la maison non plus donc ça a été un
manque aussi là maintenant euh tout ce
que j'ai pas pu faire avec les autres je
le fais avec Jade et c'est la première
fois que vous êtes père à pleinttemps
c'est ça ce que vous êtes en train de
dire oui oui très et très heureux de
l'être ça vous transforme ben je dire je
suis Amon ma
fille je suis am am mes autres enfants
aussi hein oui bon moi j'ai été élevé
par la mère par par la par la sœur de
mon père donc euh j'ai été élevé
d'ailleurs par des femmes d'ailleurs et
qui avait deux filles à l'époque qui
étaient danseuse danseuse classique à
l'Opéra de Paris et et qui ont
été qui ont été faire danser à l'Opéra
de de Londres le lac des signes
notamment où elles sont restés quelques
temps et là dest desta fils qui a
rencontré ALID qui était danseur un
danseur américain qui était venu dans
une comédie musicale qui s'appelait
oklam ils se sont rencontrés ils se sont
plus puis voilà ils sont restés ensemble
donc j'étais un petit peu trmallé comme
ça moi parce qu'après ils ont monté un
numérro de danse et moi j'étais un petit
peu trmallé de ville en ville de pays en
pays j'ai beaucoup vécu en Allemagne à
helsinky où j'ai vusy d'ailleurs c'est
c'est vrai il faut le voir pour le
croire c'est pendant 6 mois c'est la
nuit pendant 6 mois c'est le jour donc
ça je l'ai vécu et c'est vrai que
j'étais un petit peu comme un saltin ban
et puis c'est vrai que bon c'est vrai
que j'ai toujours j'ai toujours voulu
avoir une vraie famille à moi et j'avais
pas de copains parce qu'on voyait on
changeait dans endroit trop souvent donc
c'est vrai que j'avais ce côté instable
et c'est justement ce que ce que
Laeticia m'a m'a donné c'était le côté
d'avoir un foyer un foyer avec des un
enfant et peut-être deux et puis et
cetera quoi oui puisque normalement vous
devez adopter aussi une autre petite
fille oui oui on attend on attend
l'agrément
justement j'imagine quand vous êtes
entré dans leorphenina vous avvez dit
c'était un moment d'émotion intense oui
je n'avais jamais
été a si incroyable que ça puisse
paraître je n'ai jamais été dans un
orphelina de ma vie avant et je dois
dire que d'aller dans un orphelina c'est
la chose la plus terrible que que j'ai
pu que j'ai pu vivre dans ma vie de voir
tous ces bout de chou alors surtout dans
des pays comme ça bon
sont un tapis par
terre et puis on a envie de tous les
adopter quand on quand on rentre
làdedans malheureusement pour en partir
qu'avec un moi je les Auris bien tous
oui et puis alors bon il faut dire quand
même que le destin incroyable de J c'est
quand même c'est que c'est elle qui est
venu et qu'on a qu'on a pu emmener avec
nous et ça fait toujours mal au cœur de
partir d'un orphelina parce qu'on voit
tous ces autres petit bout dechou qui
sont là qui vousont regardent partir et
ENF c'est c'est quelque chose de
terrible et puis moi moi
bon j'aiess essayer de faire les choses
mieux le mieux que j'ai pu mais je crois
que partir un an tourneré comme je comme
je le fais depuis des années et des
années ça éloigne ça éloigne un peu
quand même moi j'ai envie de voir
grandir et puis surtout si si on adte
une autre petite je la voir grandir
aussi et et puis voilà et puis je ferai
quand même je fer quand même des
spectacles mais je ferai des spectacles
de temps en temps mais je ne parai plus
en tourner un an voilà pour être avec
eux tous par que oui je crois que on a
besoin on a besoin les uns des autres on
a besoin de disons qu'on besoin de
grandir ensemble vous avez le sentiment
d'avoir grandi d'être sorti justement de
l'enfance oui je je crois que depuis que
je v avec létia je crois qu'en quelque
sorte j'ai pas vieilli j'ai grandi oui
est-ce que pour autant vous dites ah
mince j'ai perdu des années si j'avais
su que c'était ça la vie de famille le
grand vous savez j'en perd jamais des
années vous savez je crois que on
profite toujours de des erreurs qu'on
qu'on peut faire dans la vie et puis et
puis les choses doivent doivent arriver
quand quand elles arrivent on peut pas
forcer le desesttin vous savez euh
moi je vois j'ai des amis autour de moi
ils sont seuls ils n'ont pas trouvé le
grand
amour bon évidemment ils s'en plignent
et il cherchent absolument de pour
trouver quelqu'un c'est pas comme ça qu'
TR la personne qui vous faut où elle
vient où elle ne viendra jamais mais on
on la rencontre par hasard c'est c'est
le destin moi je crois beaucoup au
destin mais quelle est sa botte secrète
pour vous savez si j'étais si j'étais un
homme rustre
jeiraai parce qu'elle fait bien la
cuisine ça ça serait
bist mais mais à part ça à part ça elle
fait vraiment très très
bien ça c'est drôle mais mais c'est pas
pour ça qu'elle me garde non plus non je
je pour plein de choses vous savez quand
je suis avec elle j'ai pas envie de j'ai
pas envie de partir voilà je dois aller
je dois partir faire des choses et puis
je pr mais latia c'est la mort de ma vie
mais est-ce que ça vous étonne justement
que 13 ans après vous soyez encore aussi
amoureux l'un et l'autre
ou comment comment faire pour ne pas
l'aimer cellelà pendant des années elle
m'a appelé Mamour ce qui m'énervait
profondément parce que par rapport à mes
fans c'était pas terrible parce qu'elle
le disait en publiquement maintenant
maintenant elle elle me le dit moins
elle me le dit moi mais
euh mais euh non ben elle elle arrive
pas à m'appeler Johnny
elle a jamais elle est jamais arrivé à
m'appeler Johnny mais Johnny c'est le
nom de scène oui mais tout le monde
m'appelle Johnny dire même même mes amis
oui mais elle aurait pu vous appeler de
JeanPhilippe Jean-Philippe non jamais
personne m'app Jean-Philippe non plus
alors c'est très compliqué parce que
Jean-Philippe est bon personne m'appelle
Jean-Philippe ma mère m'appel
Jean-Philippe quand j'étais plus jeune
mais part ma mère personne et et Johnny
pas ma plus Jny non plus alors pour ma
TR difficile
Mamour et aujourd'hui elle vous appelle
comment MAM touours toujours mais enfin
elle le fait plus devant tout le
monde quand on vous interview vous aimez
qu'on vous appelle Johnny ou
Jean-Philippe en fait
comment vous m'appelez pasamour ça
va pour ne rien manquer sur ma chaîne
Ina mire Duma abonnez-vous et activez la
cloche
[Musique]